What we see unlocked:...
...The invisible ties and bonds of sympathy that bring us together to become a human community.
What these pictures demonstrate is that we do feel the pain of others, however distantly.
What I think these pictures demonstrate is we do believe in something bigger than ourselves.
What these pictures demonstrate is that there is a moral sense across all religions,...
...across all faiths,...
...across all continents.
A moral sense that not only do we share the pain of others...
...and believe in something bigger than ourselves but we have a duty to act...
...when we see things that are wrong that need righted,...
...see injuries that need to be corrected,...
...see problems that need to be rectified.
There's a story about Olof Palme, the Swedish Prime Minister...
...going to see Ronald Reagan in America in the 1980s.
And before he arrived, Ronald Reagan said,...
...and he was the Swedish Social Democratic Prime Minister,...
..."Isn't this man a communist?"
And the reply was, "No, Mr. President. He's an anti-communist".
And Ronald Reagan said, "I don't care what kind of communist he is!".
And Ronald Reagan asked, Olof Palme, the Social Democratic Prime Minister of Sweden,...
..."Well, what do you believe in? Do you want to abolish the rich?".
And he said, "No, I want to abolish the poor".
Our responsibility is to let everyone have the chance to realize their potential to the full.